fox news election correspondent on our
own lawrence jones
was outside the president's rally in
erie pennsylvania and he joins us with
more lawrence what's going on
good evening sean the president was
fired up at his rally
today zeroing in on vice president joe
biden's flip-flop on fracking earlier
today i got the opportunity to talk with
the president's supporters about
fracking
how it affects them and so much more
watch
how do you feel about this race who's
going to pull off the victory in
pennsylvania i mean this is joe biden's
home state
so who wins it i don't care it's all
about trump because he cares about
everybody fracking has been a big issue
so
it's joe biden for a fracking or is he a
gift frank he flips all depends on what
they told him this morning and what
medications he's on
but i'm pretty sure that he's against it
he's flip-flopping all over the place
and i think it's going to really come
back to hurt him because the american
people we want we want to know what
you're about
and we know what president trump's about
he's been for fracking since day one
if they ban fracking from this state how
will it impact the state
that's uh it will devastate a lot of
people
it's a joke it's a joke the former
president
president obama has come into town to
campaign for joe biden will that have
any impact on pennsylvania voters i
don't believe it will
i don't believe obama's he's old news
these old news and biden is just more of
the same
sean as you know this is the vice
president's home state
it is a battleground the president won
it in 2016.
no republican had one that that state
since 1988
also all eyes on this county erie county
the president won
that county as well but again democrats
are flooding this county because they
are worried about it
we'll see what happens on election day
14 days
out sean a week from the dead all right
two weeks lj two weeks two weeks from
today all right
and uh yeah they said over and over
again they're gonna ban fracking no
doubt about it all right
lj thank you